I was waiting for a banker to drop off
some cash to me,
I only,
the only way I could you can function in
Afghanistan is you have to have cash
because there is no banking system,
there is no credit card,
there is no check.
So I had a big coat like lots of pockets
in that code and every day between 100,
$200,000 stuff in my pockets and just
pay people cash as they were.
Corruption is beyond words.
It's the second most corrupt country in
the world.
And um,
I think it's well on its way to be
number one after Somalia.
But um,
so when you see people,
um,
uh,
there is no laws,
rules or regulation,
there is.
You can go and say,
well,
I just gave you 50,000.
He could come back and say,
no you didn't.
You don't know what to do about that,
that it's not like United States while
I'm going to call my lawyer.
You just gone.
That money is gone.
So you just have to feel people and you
have to trust.
So I needed to make weekly payments to
the staff.
And the workers and a crew and he um,
told me that they cannot leave the set
because I was shooting as if you could
please bring me $50,000 by 6:00 PM at
this location.
And he said,
okay,
I'm coming with a black car.
And uh,
I'd never met him before he came.
I saw a black car parked in front.
I saw him and he says,
get in the car.
I got in the car,
we'd go out on the corner and I'll pay
you the money because I had to give
70,000.
I had 20,000 and I needed 50,000 and uh,
seven and keep going and going and
I am getting almost out of the city
completely.
And they said,
where are we going?
And he said,
well,
how much do you have?
How much do I have?
I said,
where does my money?
How much do you have?
Any what,
whether you talking about.
I said,
aren't you with the bank?
And then she'd bring me money,
black car coming in,
bringing me the money.
He just laughed.
I really like this abnoxious
laughed at.
Just chills,
you know,
in the bone.
And I looked at him,
I said,
what do you want?
And he said,
well,
I could hold you and get some money or I
could kill you and get some money,
or if you have some money you could give
it to me.
Now,
depending on how much you have.
I said I have $20,000.
It wasn't my pocket.
I handed to him.
I showed it to him.
And uh,
I said,
you,
if you take me,
nobody's going to give you money because
I've already written leather's not to
release me from the Taliban if I got
caught.
Um,
so that's useless.
but you can have this like you have to
take me back right now
and excuse me.
That's how I negotiate my deal with
them.
Um,
the next thing that happened was,
um,
I think it was for four days after that,
uh,
this guy who was writing me at security
company,
it was,
we changed security companies,
quite dolphin also because you know,
you don't know who is involved with the
security company,
you know,
one of these bodyguards which we had
between 80 and 70 a day.
One of them could be,
um,
you know,
the one that has ready to kill you.
So I was sitting in my car and I'm with
one of these bodyguards that's about
3:30 in the morning.
We're going on a set,
5:00,
then a couple of hours of category,
a little bit north of Kabul and all of a
sudden it's dark.
So I'm looking for my telephone and my
bag.
I'm searching for that lesson.
I felt something soft and I put the
light of my phone on it.
That is a hand that chopped up,
hence sitting right next to me.
Every hair on my body stood up.
I said,
oh my God.
They said to drive it.
I said,
stop the car.
dad as a hand.
And the other seat,
and he looks at me,
he goes,
oh,
I've,
when I was coming to pick you up,
there was a suicide bombing.
The windows were open and probably some
lymph fluid.
So I said,
well,
get it out of the car.
And he goes,
no,
I can stop right now.
I got to take you there.
And then I'll bury it somewhere.
I still think about that.
It just,
you honestly,
you never think something like this
could ever happen.
And then when it does happen and then
you have to live with it and it just to
see either this was planned to scare me
or if it was a fact,
the truth he was telling me
in either case it showed to me how cold
and callous people have become,
how nonimportant death is an unlimited.
The car is like not a big deal.
It just to him it was like,
yeah,
another one,
uh,
you know,
another problem that we just got to take
care of.
And the numbness that people have seen
so much death and destruction that um,
it just wasn't nothing.
I don't know which one was worse.
Finding data or finding his reaction to
it.
Um,
a lot of little stories like that
happen.